man this is the sheet so a ton of new
marketing material for Godzilla bears
Congress just dropped and there's a lot
to talk about throughout this video
we're gonna be breaking down the new
first look the Kong toy details that
give us an idea of what the acts could
be made out of and a lot more now we
will be discussing some of the plot
leaks to back things up so there will be
heavy spoilers here which means if you
don't want any of the monkey business
ruined then I recommend that you turn
off now every week we cover everything
you need to know about the movie so make
sure you stomp down that subscribe
button and please smash the thumbs up to
help us spread the good word of god
Zilla now as always welcome to there be
spoilers show I'm your host definition
aka your prime mate and with that in
trialed the way let's get into the
lowdown on the biggest battle of the
century
okay so fans have massively been
anticipating the battle between Godzilla
and Kong due to numerous delays and a
global pandemic the movies been pushed
back several times it was originally
meant to release in March and then got
pushed back to November before being
pushed back to may 2021 kind of kind of
starting a thing they should call it
Godzilla versus long because never mind
however the wheels were in motion when
it came to the marketing material and a
lot of Thai companies have stuck sitting
around that they need to shift so
they've started to put them out as per
was agreed in that original contract
these days toy companies make their
action figures alongside the studio so
they can have a release that allows kids
to go and watch the movies and then
guilt-trip their parents into buying
them things which great it's worked so
far brilliantly now if you don't know
this tradition dates all the way back to
Star Wars and you hope when the movie
was first released toy companies tended
to start working on figures after the
film came out and thus due to the
popularity of the movie this caused all
the corporations to lose a lot of money
the companies were unable to fulfill the
supply and demand and Star Wars toys
were delayed which sucked if you were a
fan of the film
I just wanted to bust out a lightsaber
and and hit someone in the face at the
time parents even had to give their kids
vouchers for Christmas so they knew a
toy was coming
actually it just they just wouldn't have
it anytime soon which feels a bit like
Godzilla miss Kong as well now since
then toy companies have had access to
things early and this is why elements of
movies are often spoiled at toy fairs we
saw this in the case of cheetah recently
who still hasn't fully been revealed for
Wonder Woman 84 but we know what she's
gonna look like because of the toys
however sometimes companies aren't given
full access and this is why we got a
Robin figure for Batman Returns when he
wasn't even in the movie which as a four
year old broke my heart I'm not gonna
lie anyway you're not here to listen to
me ramble about the inner workings of
the commodity and franchise
opportunities that are offered to
plastic companies you here to hear me
talk about the sneak peek of the movie
that was placed on the back of the
playmates toy figures but just bear all
of the aforementioned information in
mind as we discuss things now when this
dropped everyone jumped on it and
claimed it was a first proper look at
the film an amazing teaser that showed
The Clash of the Titans finally going
down personally I think it seems more
like concept art of a scene that will
likely happen in the movie and rather
than being a photographic image it just
gives us an idea of how this will play
out we did actually see a leaked image
from the film that was very similar to
this one which I don't want to show as
Warner Brothers have been copyright
claiming it but chances are you've seen
it by now it is extremely similar this
one so we do know from this that this
art will be a moment that appears in the
movie I don't think it seems like it's
still from the film due to air appearing
his artwork rather than a photograph but
even then it's still very detailed and
does give us a lot of information the
image shows the two Titans tearing it up
on top of an aircraft carrier and I love
how they're just going at it whilst the
humans are trying to take them down they
don't even seem to be bothered by what's
being fired at them and according to
leaks on the movie we will be getting a
5 minute long fight scene that doesn't
cut away to whatever it is Mellie Bobby
Brown's up to the fight is definitely
the main selling point of the film and
it of course should be the focus 5 year
old me is crying right now and 32 year
old me is like let them fight this is
what we want to see and the prior films
in my opinion become a bit bogged down
in the human side of things so I'm glad
that we're just getting some focus on
the things that we're all actually here
to see the image also clearly detailed
Kong and Godzilla being pretty much the
same height now either my man's been
hitting those lockdown gains or
something else has happened to him with
there being a big time difference
between Kong Skull Island and this movie
it is possible that he's grown a fair
few inches in that time character and
not having King in front of his name
could show that he was still pretty much
a kid back then a thousand year old kid
or whatever it is but since the 70s he's
clearly grown a lot now we don't know
this for definite and I kind of had my
own thoughts on it that are based off
some of the pot leaks now according to
those leaks Kong will have roamed the
Hollow Earth and I have a theory that
the nuke which was set off in king of
the monsters could have potentially
given him a radiation boost and thus he
grew a bit more maybe's clicked one of
those internet adverts that can help you
grow six inches we don't know but
they're definitely more on a level
playing field with one another
so yeah this image finally quells all
those rumours of Kong being too small to
fight Godzilla and I'm glad that they
were approaching it with them sort of
being the same height still though
Godzilla should have in pretty beat
right well your boy Kong has some tricks
up his sleeve and we can see in a
close-up of the toy for the character
that he will be brandishing an axe this
is something that we've talked about in
the plot leaks so far and it was
revealed that there's a cave painting on
Skull Island which shows the two facing
off against each other the showdown has
been prophesized for centuries due to
the Kong's anger jiriz being mortal
enemies with one another and thus the
Islanders that worship Kong have helped
him out by building a great axe made out
of a giant tree and boulder however it
looks like this axe goes beyond that and
that the blade on it has been ripped off
Godzilla's back and has been placed into
the weapon this if true is completely
amazing and it really shows that Kong is
just going all out in order to fight
against the giant lizard it doesn't look
like Godzilla's taking it lying down
though and on the toei of Kong we can
see three core marks across his chest
which
have clearly caused scars the toy also
reveals that Kong's arm is getting torn
into and yeah that looks like it really
hurts this isn't some little scabby get
on your leg when you fall over the skin
is being torn off right down to the
muscle itself and it looks like Kong is
gonna have to learn how to choke the
monkey where there's other hand now we
haven't seen any images of Mechagodzilla
yet but we do know that they probably
will be coming soon according to the
plot leaks Kong and Godzilla go
head-to-head
after being manipulated to fight one
another by a company called apex that
have made the to turn against one
another in order to wipe them out whilst
they're at the weakest they create
Mechagodzilla from the Gojira bone seen
in the first film and the Ghidorah head
that was teased at the end of king of
the monsters according to the leaks
Godzilla wins and is just about to kill
him when he says save mah Mothra save
Mothra yeah have that no you know what
yeah that's a brilliant joke and you all
hate him but now according to the plot
leaks Godzilla wins and then mecha
godzilla arrives they fight and that
leads to the pair beating it and going
on to become the rulers of their
respective lands kong becomes king kong
ruler of the Hollow Earth and Godzilla
becomes the king of the monsters once
more and at the ruler of natural order
now we can't confirm this for definite
yet but if we're following the rules of
versus movies then the first name on the
flier is usually the one that wins
except for when it's not now again all
of this could just be like what happened
in the case of Robin and Batman Returns
in that it doesn't actually feature in
the film however I do think that with
the actual concept art itself this will
be in the movie
due to the leaked image that pretty much
portrayed this scene however as for Kong
basically getting his bicep ripped off
we're gonna have to wait and see as I'm
still unsure on that one battle damaged
figures often tend to go a bit above and
beyond what actually happens in the
movie so if I had to say whether any of
this would be happening or not I would
probably put my money on the concept art
one being right and the bicep one being
still up in the air now that is because
I just can't see how you could come back
from that as it looks like it's gonna
get really badly infected
either way though I'm really hyped for
the movie and this first look feels like
it's been a long time coming I really
hope that the trailer rumors are true
and that we get something before the end
of the month but as always I'll keep my
eyes peeled and be on the lookout for
new information as it arrives anyway
that's pretty much everything you need
to know about the movie the first look
and the toys there is a lot to talk
about so if you have anything you want
to add then make sure you comment below
and let me know if you missed our last
video then make sure you check it out
after this as we talk about the trailer
date brand-new rumours plot leaks and a
lot more every month we give away free
movies too people are subscribed to the
channel and this month he came on the
MCU infinitely saga box set and all you
have to do is comment on a video and
make sure you subscribe with
notifications on the more videos he
comment on the more you a chance of
winning so make sure you get involved
the winners gonna be chosen at random on
the 15th of august and the set will be
shipped out from then Tova gets the
prize so best of luck to everyone who
takes part you wanna come chat us after
the show either follow us that heavy
spoilers or click the discord link in
the description below those are the best
ways cuba today with a channel so
hopefully you see over there but if not
have a great week I'll see you next time
take care mate peace
you
[Music]